hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play the
unfair platformer now once again I am
back to my normal calm cool and
collected state however the level that
we are on is not neither Tom nor cool
nor collected because I had to use a
level coach I didn't I kind of lost all
my progress that I had in this level not
saying that I had any but also my live
cat ago who said so we're starting fresh
hooray not gonna die because his giant
ass Boulder right behind me and I'm
going to dodge these so approach fudge
oh no big deal no big deal not gonna
bother me because I wait a minute how
did I get through that before oh yeah I
remember now okay got it got it got it
nailing it now that's okay it happens
worse things have happened I think we're
gonna be okay or we're gonna die a bunch
right here which is cool too because I
don't I don't have anything better to do
with my time
okay which one was the bow is that
Trixie one okay I can remember this
maybe okay which one is the double one
right there so then I can go over it
here what that was gone that wasn't even
there anymore okay mother of nope nope
nope nope nope
why on him why not find every way that I
can die before I'm allowed to move on
just skip over those jump over here get
away from that's okay that's okay
everybody okay everybody not gonna speak
any foreign languages here because I am
totally calm and rather okay alright
okay I need a vacation I play too many
of these rage games to be good for me
so then I can just yeah yes got the
checkpoint okay so now I can like at
five
I can I can dub what
that wasn't even a thing there there was
no arrow what are you talking about
that arrow is gone it's non-lethal at
that point that one was lethal that one
got me right in my noggin ah I will
commend you why can't I get up on this
stupid block right here
there we go that's what I was supposed
to do from the beginning oh that's how
it's good a bit right oh that's how you
got what okay see I'm going to boot
whoo ha maan oh good tell all not to get
the arrow in your face get to the arrow
away from your face and you'll be a
third yeah 30 good darn it
go shoot McGillicuddy oh [ __ ] mom I
can't do this I can't do this it's
impossible that's just unfair Tim it's
impossible I'm pressing the jump button
and this thing is not responding
correctly to my commands jump over it ah
never mind I'm beginning to think that
unfair mario was inspired by this game
and it's not the other way around which
may have been said in the comics but I
don't know because I wasn't really them
how am I supposed to get past those
anyway oh come on let me through how
about instead of jumping in a gap
between the blocks we jump right on the
blocks cuz that seems like it'd be
easier considering there's two of them
and only one gap oh I'm gonna okay so I
got a I can just jump down here and then
jump up here and then jump over there
and jump how is that possible
okay come on come on yeah just got up
mmm how did I do this before I did it
nice and smooth that wasn't it but I'll
take it
oh come on wha where did I go what
happened I don't even understand what
happened there doesn't make any star I
spit I spit all over myself I'm dude so
angry look it goes billows you come on
what are you doing guy oh man come on
just go would work with me okay the
first one not and then I can't get past
it to the other one
[Music]
whoo-whoo-whoo - gosh I can't do this
Jokke sake whoa I get so frustrated I
swear and it's so damn hot in my room
come on okay just calm down take this
one step at a time because I am a
professional gamer who is used to going
through a lot worse than this I can I
can make I can make that can make that
dig down and then we go up okay I got
dropped down first but I can make come
on I had a man to go back for words I
meant to go back for words hard and oh
god stop out how in the hell am I
supposed maybe not go up this oh I got
it oh I know your secrets I know your
secret now I know your secrets now no I
was supposed to jump up there
fuj okay nope nope okay come on
just work with me here okay go down Oh
okay go up and now go down yes yes I
knew it I knew that was the secret and
then we just we jumped but we weren't
supposed to just meander off into the
abyss I don't blame this guy though if I
was if I was oh how do that before I
thought I'd touch that one before it
went over I just fine time speak English
anymore apparently not oh god I'm gonna
lose my mind this is absolutely
incredible impossible I thought that
before and it didn't do end what girl
returned your advice I'm not angry just
finished shooting out of my mouth
uncontrollably this is be hideous is
what oh okay so I gotta get through here
no okay come on come on come on come on
please please please please okay stop
here
Oh bye you scared me I jumped off
because I was so afraid of what was
gonna happen to me my beautiful face
okay so what happens if I just stop here
he's gonna get me
[Music]
why the hell am i put leap over the rock
talk dirty to the rock Oh Rock you so
hard oh yeah no talk not dirty to the
rock Oh da Rock you're looking so good
for game you're a successful person
you're running a good business killing
people it's really fantastic I love the
way that you make me I want to rip my
hair out and go to go to bed and fall
asleep
I hope this nightmare ends someday it
won't end the nightmare never ends what
am I talking about
I'm ever so much fun
I'm having fun doing this this is all
this is oh come on why do you decide to
sometimes hit it and not hit why does it
sometimes decide to do it and I'm so
angry I can only express my emotions
through interpretive death I'm so also
sweating so damn hot in my room air
conditioner doesn't work I rocked on
more deaths I did the first part I'm not
even 10 minutes then why I need a sweat
rag here cuz I'm about to die oh no my
hair my perfect cow okay no one wants
the point to go away I can't change my
hairstyle forever now oh why do you
decide some why now what am i doing
differently oh come on
I even wonder if I get down here I
wouldn't know what to do
LVPD my brain is officially broken or
some down there oh I have hope
I have hope now I finally have some hope
that I'm going to get out of this and
how where is it
it's down there I know I've always down
there I'm sorry as a south floors but
that's okay
this is gonna be gorgeous funny it's
gonna be good it's gonna be worth it I'm
in it I'm on yeah there's gonna be sure
hey almost a hundred deaths how cool am
I not very cuz I'm very hot right now oh
it's so hot I'm just good alright it
really it's like burning up in my
apartment and I'm me yelling and
screaming is not helping okay there's
something down here work I see you I see
it where is it it's like this tiny
sliver of something I've been forwards
and I've been backwards but I can't seem
to pinpoint its location where the all
100/100 death went came and went okay
good good signifying the summation of my
experience in this game a crappy there's
something down there I know this I know
this I know this
you can't me I know this I know I'm
gonna get this I'm gonna get this on my
drowning in sweat mother oh okay that -
alright then why not you know why not
I'm just gonna I'm gonna lose my mind
okay there we go okay come on come on
pounce ah
I'm holding the up button I usually just
make some jump but it's not doing it
it's not doing I know if this is like
not the way to do it I'm gonna be so
pissed
god no I buddy the other one ma this is
all my fault
I chose
this I chose this life I chose this life
come on oh maybe I gotta wait till the
oh oh I got it I got it I gotta wait
there for a second and then wait here
until now
Oh close close close close close oh I'm
on the right track I know I am I'm in
sorrow and pain
I just nothing will save my mind after
this one oh why oh baby there's nothing
down there let's find nothing done it's
all a lie the big troll just to give me
false sliver of hope how are you Joe I
swear I'm stomping on something I'm just
I'm just ah let's just turn this into
something else let's turn this into
funny markiplier voice our whoa kid
welcome to the hundred and 17th
anniversary of my death aren't you all
hello let's make that 118 okay
I'm tired of that already I'm not in the
mood for cheerfulness and any sort of
happy logs
I can't do it I can't do it I give up I
give up I give up I give up one more
time
ah I'm a charge of the rock and
eventually the amount of number of
bodies that I throw it it will cause it
to degrade I think after a few million
deaths I'll finally be able to get
through this sumbitch well let's get
gutted no time to waste uh yeah
I've got nothing nothing nothing nothing
absolutely nothing that could possibly
be in the hair so I'm done forever I'm
gonna go kill myself go go jump off the
back of an ice-cream truck double
somersault into a pile of nails and then
eat the nails and then let them puncture
me from the inside out then I'm gonna
light myself on fire and throw myself in
a bag of manure I'll throw myself down
to hell so I roll it a flaming bag of
manure full of nails and I'm gonna blow
up into a factory up pillows or kittens
or something I don't know something nice
so I can blow off and destroy I oh no
I'm done so anyway if you want to tell
me how to do this show me fun I'm not
gonna look it up thank you all so much
for watching click the annotation for
more videos that I've done and as always
I will see you in the next video
[Music]
okay
Oh